(Cuban dance music)
- [Kadir Lopez Nieves] Walking
through the city of Havana,
one day I look up, and one of
the oldest neon signs was off.
I realized I should just
do something with it.
I do see the future of
the beauty of the city
related with the past, and
that past was the neon.
- [Narrator] Cuban
artist Kadir López Nieves
is bringing new light and
life to the streets of Havana
by restoring the city's
neon signs one-by-one
with his project, Havana Light.
Many of these signs have
sat abandoned for decades.
- [Kadir] In the '50s and '40s,
there was the renaissance
of the neon in Cuba,
thousands of neon all
over the city of Havana.
The neon was part of the architecture.
- [Narrator] But in the
1960s, the neon signs
became difficult and expensive
to maintain, and slowly
they were taken down or
shut off and left to decay.
- [Kadir] Today, the neon is considered
like a piece of art in itself.
The mission is taking the art outside.
People walking in the
street, they don't have to be
into the museum to look
into a piece of art.
- [Narrator] Over the past
three years, Kadir and his team
have restored dozens of
signs across the city.
It can be a painstaking process.
- It's no different
than fixing an old car.
You take all the elements
out and you start
fixing everything that
is rusted or damaged.
The most difficult thing is the bending.
It's a skill that very few
people have in the world.
So, the most complicated
process is taking it down
and lifting it up, 'cause
you need a lot of men.
Certain places like Old
Havana, you gotta do it
by rope, by hand, because big cars
and cranes, they cannot get in there.
It is phenomenal to see
the people's reaction.
In some cases, we see kind
of tears in their eyes.
They get so excited about seeing something
that was about to disappear
coming back to life.
Neon ...
it means a restoration ...
of hope.
You make people's lives happier.
There's nothing stronger than that.